foreign
yesterday yesterday Joe I come in I get
off the plane get on the couch Tom takes
a [ __ ] I play with his kids for a little
bit his oldest comes in and goes hey
Bert I got you a cup of water and I go
thanks buddy I was on a plane all day
and time goes hold on hold on Ellis
where did you get that from and he goes
the sink and he goes else you can't
reach the sink you get that from the
toilet and he goes no and I go did you
just get a cup of water from the toilet
and he goes no I'll go take a sip of
this water and use no
I go sit my water before I get it and he
goes no I go where'd you get this water
he goes this Tom knows he got it and
this kid is straight [ __ ] face
and he goes take a step Bert take a sip
and I go no I'm not taking this up your
[ __ ] water okay you take a sip he
goes I'm not taking a sip you take a sip
and then Tom goes in he goes don't touch
the water it's from the [ __ ] toilet
there was a water trail from the toilet
to the [ __ ] couch and he goes Alice
did you get that from the [ __ ] toilet
and he goes I did I just walked out of
the room
I looked at Tom I was like please take
me to my room I'm gonna lock my [ __ ]
doors the kid just wanted the kitchen to
drink toilet he goes and from the
[ __ ] toilet dude what's that kid
gonna be like when he's 15.
15.
[Music]